私はミュージシャンだと思います
ので、フルーティスト
、作曲家、音楽
評論家として40年以上のプロとしてのキャリアを持ち、この40年間
で200以上の老人ホームを訪れました。
多くの認知症患者のために演奏した
ことがありますもちろん、認知症と
は日本語で大丈夫だということを知っているので、今日は
あなたに話しますが、私は
音楽で認知症患者のためにやっているので、
先に進む前に私のオリジナルの曲の1つを演奏させてください
最初の曲のタイトル
は捨てられたラボですこれは私が世界中の
すべてのストリートの子供たちのために作曲したこの音楽
は一種の祈りの歌なので、
楽しんでいただければ幸いです
私
には距離がありますそれ
は私にとって非常に自然に見えるのは大丈夫ですが、
認知症患者の前で演奏するとき
は受け入れられませんなぜ
認知症患者の前で演奏するときは
あなたの尊敬とdを示さなければならないのでなぜ受け入れられないのですか そうでなければ、
音楽はその
音楽が彼らの傷に身に着けるために届かないところに届かない
ので、私は
認知症患者がナーシングホームで大丈夫になる前にどのように演奏するかについてあなたに話さなければなりませ
ん すでに
答えましたあなたは私が今聴衆の中で何をしたか覚えていません
これを説明させてください私
があなたの近くで演奏した3つの
ヒントがあり
ます 私は同じレベルで遊んでいまし
た見下ろして
いません見上げていませんでしたあなたは同じレベルでプレイしなければなりませんでした
認知症患者に敬意と尊厳を示すための3つのヒントは非常に役立ちます
が、残念ながら
、ほとんどのナーシングホームで彼女を見たというこのような態度は
見たことがありませ
ん。
認知症私はシュールではありません e
彼らの行動についてどれだけ知っているか
認知症患者の典型的な行動は
もちろん認知症の原因によって異なります
が
、2つの側面があります彼らの行動には2つの側面があります
それ
はほぼ完全に反対
です 1つは、このように1
日中椅子に座って、
何も話さずに何もせずに
1日中落ち着いてください。この場合、
何を言っても反応しないため、コミュニケーションが非常に困難です。 どのよう
に大丈夫と話すか、そして第2の側面の第2の
行動それははるかに積極的です
大丈夫彼らはいつも怒っています怒って
イライラし、不平を言い、叫ぶ
こともあります
私には数回大丈夫なので
、これらの2つの異なる種類の側面があっても、これを覚えて
おく必要が
あります。これが原因であるとは信じられないかもしれません。
lあなたが知っているこれらの2つの異なる種類のユーロのこのフォームを知っているのと同じようにあなた
は認知症患者の行動を知っています
理由は1つです理由は
大丈夫です理由は
混乱と不安です
彼らは
何か大丈夫なことを恐れているので
、この混乱や不安を取り除きたいのであれば
、私が音楽を演奏するのと同じように、
私たちは曲を見ています。
また、今説明した3つのヒントを覚えています。
あなたが
このように音楽を作るなら、あなたは
音楽への反応がどれほど速いかに驚くでしょう
それはとても速いので大丈夫あなたは
これが大丈夫だとは信じられないでしょ
う
一度に1つ
ずつそれはすぐには機能しません
または多分あなたが知っている毒がすぐに機能します
そしてそれから私たちは
もっと多くの錠剤が機能しない方法を知っていますダグ
どこでも音楽は音楽が
すぐに機能するので私が行く前に私はあなたが欲しい
1つ覚えて 世界のすべての認知症患者の最後のことは、非常に
多くの人が非常に多く、すべてが内部で生きて
いることです。もちろん、脳の
内部で、音楽は常に
記憶を取り戻し、彼らの生活を取り戻すための最大のトリガーです。
それ
が音楽の力です。私は
これを信じています。同じようにすれば、世界中
の多くの認知症患者を救うことができると確信しています。
ありがとうござい
ます